MIKE DENNY: Hello everyone.
And welcome to the
Design Fireside Chat
at Google I/O 2016.
My name is Mike Denny.
I am a Design Advocate on
the Google Design team.
And today, we
really want to have
an informal, casual
conversation.
We've gathered five Design
leaders from across Google,
from different disciplines,
different teams.
And we really want
to have this session
be a cross-section of what it
looks like to design at Google,
the processes, how we
think about things,
and really hoping that you
enjoy the conversation.
We've solicited questions
on social media.
We've come up with
some of our own.
And we're really looking for
that kind of holistic design
at Google feeling.
So we're going to start
with some introductions.
We're just going to kind of give
each panelist a couple minutes
to introduce themselves,
their background,
where they came
from before Google,
and what they do at Google.
And then we'll get
into some questions.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: I'll start.
I'm Nicholas Jitkoff.
I am a sort of
Design and Eng lead
on the Material Design team.
I actually started out
like out of college
working for a financial firm
and started writing software
on the side and parlayed that
into coming here as a software
engineer, originally.
I've been at Google for
eight or nine years or so but
have moved over time
from software engineering
into doing more
of a design role,
but still working pretty
actively with engineers
and also with product
and marketing people.
A lot of the work the
Material team does
tends to span across a lot
of those different efforts.
We touch branding.
We touch the products
that are being built.
MARTA REY-BABARRO: Hi, I'm
Marta, the lead researcher
for CorpEng UX, which
is an internal team that
work on internal websites and
applications for Googlers world
wide.
I also started my UX
career in finance,
in a bank in Spain at the
beginning of the 2000s, when
all the companies were going
crazy into having presence
online.
And we didn't know
what we were doing yet
at the end of the 90s.
So I started, and it
became a passion of mine.
And I came to the US
from Spain 13 years ago,
and loving being here.
KEVIN DAME: Hello, I'm Kevin.
And I have been at Google
for 3 and 1/2 years.
I work in YouTube.
And my background is
sort of a combination
of a few different
mini careers-- part
engineer, part designer,
part marketer slash MBA.
And all of that sort
of led me to Google.
I worked at IDEO.
That was my last-- the
company I worked at before.
I was there for a very
long time, 11 years.
And when I decided
to join Google,
I was really
curious about trying
to blend the best of what
I'd learned at IDEO, which,
to me, felt like a great
company to learn at, and then
blend that with Google, which
is another great company that
does a lot of things.
And in some ways, the
companies are similar,
some ways the companies
are a little bit different.
And so what I've been doing
over the last few years
is I created a group at YouTube
called the Visioning Team which
is an attempt from me to sort
of blend these different methods
together to identify areas
for innovation for YouTube
and help teams define a clear
path forward for their product.
KATHERINE WALKER: Hi.
I'm Katherine.
I work on Google's Brand Studio.
Brand Studio is actually on
the marketing side of Google.
And we're sort of
in a unique position
where we work with all different
product teams and marketing
teams across Google.
So we try to connect the dots.
We are comprised of strategists,
filmmakers, designers,
developers.
And most of our
projects range in size
from creating new identities
to Chrome extensions
to even worrying
about packaging tape,
I mean, all sorts of things.
I, originally, my background,
I wanted to be a cartoonist.
So it really wasn't so much
in the technology sphere.
I wanted to do
political cartooning.
But then when I
got to art school,
I really fell in love with
brand design and typography.
I am obsessed with typography
and systems of brand design,
so with anything
that has like a font
stint to it, that's
where I like to be.
ALEX COOK: Hey.
So I'm Alex.
And I've worked at Google
for almost 11 years now.
It still feels
like I'm relatively
new to Google because everything
changes every day there.
I'm really excited to be
working on the Google Assistant.
So I'm a Design Lead
on that project.
And I'm also working on a
bunch of new initiatives
that we have in and around
Search and Maps, which
is my home base.
And one of the things that
I'm really excited about
is bringing in some
new roles into UX,
such as motion design
and UX Engineering,
which are some things
we've been building up
over the last few years.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Thank you, everybody.
So to get started, I
think the first question
I'd like to have
us talk about is
more on the process side of
things, how we approach things.
And I think we'll
start with Kevin.
But I think maybe
multiple people
will be able to weigh
in just because Google's
a large company, different
teams do things different ways.
How do teams at
Google decide what
to build before
actually building it?
KEVIN DAME: Yeah, so I can talk
a little bit about what we're
doing on the
Visioning team and how
we're trying to enhance our
process at YouTube to do that.
It's a little daunting, because
when I joined Google and joined
YouTube, I was
interested in evolving
our processes to be better.
But you have to come in with
a little bit of humility
because it's a very,
very successful company.
So you don't want to come in
and say, well, that's wrong.
What are we doing?
So had to kind of
think about ways
to address-- but
also at Google, we
want to-- I think
part of our culture
is to keep getting better.
So people are very open
to, how can we be better?
So I'll talk about
three things that we
try to do in the
Visioning team to help.
And again, we're working
on kind of the early stage.
So if you think about product
development, which is designing
and developing and
building a product,
product vision is kind of the
step before that which is well,
what should we build before
we start going and building?
How do we figure out what
the right thing to build is?
We could build 1,000
different things,
but what's the
right thing to do?
So I'd say that from
a process perspective
there's a few things
that we're trying
to do that are a little bit
different maybe than what
the norm is in
the tech industry.
So the first one is we
try to think about-- some
of this probably sounds obvious.
But I think when you're
in the thick of things
it can be very
difficult to do, which
is-- what we try to
do is focus on what's
the ideal product that we
could get to in a couple years.
Not four or five years out
because the tech industry
changes a lot.
But what's the ideal
experience we can get to.
That's a little bit
different that I
think may be more of a lean
approach, which the tech
industry often uses, which
is let's just build something
as quickly as possible, get
it out there, and then learn.
I think that's still
a great philosophy.
But we want to put just
a little bit more rigor
in thinking about
what's the thing we
want to shoot for before
we put something out there.
Second thing is this
idea of-- and it really
relates to the first
thing as well--
which is we want to
feel like we have--
if we are going to put
something out in the marketplace
and then learn, we feel like
that's kind of an expensive way
to learn.
So how can we fail
faster and more often
internally with rough
prototypes, really quick ways
to explore many
different things so
that when we do
converge on something,
probably take a
little bit longer.
But then when we converge
on it, our odds of success
are much higher.
And the third thing that we try
to do from a process standpoint
is this idea of Visioning.
You know, I think that
traditionally, sometimes people
think that it's either like the
leader of the organization who
creates the vision and then
kind of tells everybody.
Or sometimes people think, well,
that's a product manager's job.
What we try to do is
democratize product vision.
What we try to do
is get everybody
on the team to participate
in that process
so that instead of someone
telling them, well,
here's the vision, now
go design against it,
everybody on the
team has participated
and feel like they own
and buy the vision.
So that's what we try to do on
the Visioning team at YouTube.
MIKE DENNY: I'm wondering,
Marta, maybe you
could chime in on
design sprints.
MARTA REY-BABARRO:
Yeah, totally.
So I arrived to Google
around three years ago.
CorpEng UX was a very tiny team.
We were only four
people in the team.
And we were redesigning a very
big product, internal product,
which is the Performance
Evaluation tool.
The deadlines were crazy.
And there was no time for
design, no time for research.
And at the time, we had a ton
of meetings, ton of meetings,
half decisions were
made here, then
another decision was
made in another meeting.
So it was a very
difficult process.
So one of the things
that I thought was,
why don't we bring
everyone to a room,
and we make the decisions
that we need to make?
Let's clear our
agendas for five days.
And let's give everyone a
voice, engineering-- whoops,
and it did fall.
OK.
MIKE DENNY: We can
still hear you.
MARTA REY-BABARRO:
You can still hear me?
OK, great.
So let's give
Engineering a voice.
There are a lot of engineering
constraints around these tools.
We are migrating from
old code to a new code,
so what are the
constraints that we have?
That designers, as well.
We had a ton of research done.
We had business needs.
So let's give everyone
in the room a voice.
And once we all know what
is the space in which we
are designing, then
let's make decisions.
And it was a gigantic success.
So from a team of
people in which we
had a very tight deadline,
we were working crazy hours,
to a process that ended up
being much more organized,
where features ended up being
built within only five days.
And everyone was more
in the same page.
So after that, design
sprinting became a thing--
like one of the ways,
one of the processes
that we have internally
to re-design tools,
come up with new tools, come
up with visions for tools,
think about completely new tools
that don't exist right now.
And it all starts by
understanding the space
from everyone's point of view.
And it's exciting.
It's a very exciting
way of working.
Because everyone
feels very energized.
People don't feel that they
are in just like one space,
either designing or coding.
But everyone is in the same
room, making these decisions.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Awesome.
So anyone jump into this.
This is a broad question
that probably we all
have an experience with.
What defines a good
relationship between you
as a designer and
another discipline?
I know that we're
all kind of cross--
There's a lot of
disciplines represented here
in our backgrounds.
We're all doing design-y
stuff now, right?
So How do you approach that
kind of work flow collaboration
between someone who might
not understand your skill
set, and you might
not understand theirs?
ALEX COOK: I think it's a
combination of conversation
and mutual respect.
So the end of the day, everybody
wants to do the same thing.
We want to ship
something really great.
We want to get that
out to our users.
And we want the
feature or the product
that we're working on
to be really successful.
The difference
comes down to people
have differences of opinion
of what that should be,
and how you should get there.
And so you solve those
through conversation.
And having a closer loop
between Design and Engineering
makes it possible
to work out things
as they arise on the fly, and
to have the conversations.
Oh, we can't do this, what
can we do as an alternate?
Or, hey, I thought of this idea.
Maybe Eng's bringing
about some design ideas.
They should be part
of the conversation,
too, because in the end,
they're responsible for the user
experience of the
product as well.
And the mutual respect
thing comes down to,
at the end of the day,
designers have to do design
and engineers have
to do engineering.
So at some point,
you have to say,
you know what, I trust this
person to do what they do.
I know they're making
good decisions.
And I'm going to
let them run with it
and empower them to make the
decisions they need to make.
KATHERINE WALKER:
I'm with you on that.
Trust is huge.
And I ask a million questions.
I work with engineers on a
lot of the brand identities
that we do.
And I, frankly, I don't know
how they do what they do.
So I ask all the time.
And I've kind of
explained to them,
since [INAUDIBLE] had this
waterfall approach, where I'll
say, OK, move the
design, make it
look like that, with no context,
when you're not giving context
to the decisions you
make, you kind of feel
like you're at odds.
But one thing that's
really been useful,
especially with collaborations
with other disciplines,
is that everyone is at the
table at the very beginning
of the project.
So we all know what
the common goal is.
We all know what the
user expectation is.
And we all know what
success might look like,
and what the expectations
for the project are.
I think that when not
everyone's in the room
to hear when things kick
off or get the entire brief,
it's much harder for everyone
to be on the same page.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Yeah.
I mean, with both
of those questions,
we've been talking about
kind of getting people
from all the different
disciplines together--
the decision makers, the
designers, the developers--
in the same room before you
invest in actual product
design and development.
What's the best way to get
engineers and decision makers
involved early on in the
design process-- in particular,
with research, with things
that we do as designers
at the early stages.
How can we better involve
engineers in that process?
ALEX COOK: Scotch tape.
Scotch tape is the answer.
KEVIN DAME: I was
going to answer.
And then I was like
well, I'm not ready.
So hopefully he'll lengthen the
question a little bit longer
so I'll be ready.
I do have a thought on that.
Because I think
that's-- First of all,
I want to underscore this idea
of getting people in a room
together for maybe a
day or two to work.
It sounds, again, so basic.
But when I joined Google, what
I noticed-- and this is probably
true of most of tech
world and even corporate
America-- is people actually
don't get a lot of time
together to actually
collaborate.
They'll have a status meeting.
But there's a lot of
these tiny little shards
of communication and comments
in docs and email threads.
And it's just,
there's so much power
in just this basic concept of
getting people in the room,
getting the right
people in the room.
But one thing that we do
to get people involved.
So in our Visioning
projects, like I said,
we want this to be a
democratic process.
One of the things
that is required
to do that is
actually to rethink
the relationships a little
bit that we talked about just
a minute ago, which is that for
most of product development,
it makes sense to
have researchers
who have spent their
whole career-- they have
a Ph.D in research--
and engineers
who are good at engineering
to have that specialization.
But in the Visioning
process, we actually
take a very different
approach, which is
take your functional hat off.
Because now, at
the very beginning
of this Visioning
project, we're going
to go learn about our user.
So you're all researchers today.
In my first year at Google,
I sent 15 people out
to different schools
around the Bay Area.
Because we were looking at the
classroom, the whole education
area.
And I told them,
you're all researchers.
And they were, what?
I've never been a
researcher before.
Where's my discussion guide?
What do I do?
I don't have a Ph.D.
It's basically like look,
you can go to a school.
And you can have a
conversation with the teacher.
And you can be curious
and listen and just
be curious about what
it's like to be a teacher.
And so the philosophy
is like today,
we're all going to
be a researcher.
Tomorrow, we're all
going to be designers.
We're going to create ideas.
Now we're going
to bring users in.
We're all going to be
researchers, again.
So the way we get involvement
is to kind of take
the functional hats
on and really back up
the words, which is no, we
really want you to be involved.
Here's your notebook, you're
going to go learn about a user.
We're relying on you to
come back with good insight.
So that's how we do it
on the Visioning team.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
To build on that,
Marta, how do we
select-- how do you
choose the right people?
I mean, you don't want it to
be too big of a team, right?
How do you pick the
right people from all
these different disciplines?
MARTA REY-BABARRO:
It's so funny.
When I teach the
Academy with Kai,
who's another co-founder
of the Design Sprint
Academy at Google, we tell
people a good number of people
is between like five
and eight people.
Like a very small team you
can work together five days,
very, very focused.
So that's what I teach.
The reality, now, in CorpEng
is that the last sprint, I
had 31 people.
And I started that
meeting saying,
you guys, I know
everyone likes sprinting.
We need to be talking, everyone.
And they started adding
people, this director
and that director.
And then at the end, we
couldn't cut a single person.
So we ended up
making it happen--
a very, very successful sprint
with 30 people sprinting
at the same time,
communicating with each other
during several
moments of the day.
So that was quite fun.
So I would say, ideally,
between five and eight people,
have the right
people in the room,
the people that are
decision makers.
So you definitely need
Engineering there.
You definitely need Design.
You need UX there.
You need the user.
Being in a room, thinking
about how something
could be for a user and not
getting that user input,
it's a beautiful exercise
that it might not work.
So having that, and
then also having
the business perspective.
There is a lot of knowledge
about the space, right?
If we're designing a
new product that it's
going to be launching in two
years, what's our competition?
What is the landscape?
So all that knowledge
needs to be in that room.
And the right people.
And then the decision makers.
So it's a very good idea
to invite directors or VPs
to kick off that sprint or
come to the last presentation
or participate.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, you've mentioned a
couple times kind of this--
you've mentioned five days.
You mentioned a specific
range, five to eight people.
But at the end of the day,
these design processes
need to be flexible.
MARTA REY-BABARRO: Yeah.
MIKE DENNY: And you mentioned
Kai Haley, actually,
another designer at Google who
works a lot on design sprints.
And she gave a talk
earlier at Google I/O
about using this
design sprint approach,
and being able to
feel comfortable
being flexible with that.
So if you didn't
get that session,
check it out on YouTube.
And we want to shift
gears, now, into kind
of beyond the initial process
and into actual, collaborative
design and development.
And maybe Nicholas, you
can take this first.
How do you handle large scale?
I mean Google is a fairly large
company with some big ideas
and some big projects.
How do you handle these
large scale design or brand
deployments things?
I mean, lots of new
announcements, recently
did a big logo redesign,
the Assistant, right?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
A lot of the stuff
that-- the small problems that
you sort of face within a team,
you see in larger form across
a larger company-- trying
to get sort of tight
iteration loops between teams
becomes a challenge
rather than trying
to get it between just
design and engineering.
In many cases, for things
like logo redesigns
or anything where it's going
to touch multiple products,
you need feedback
from those products.
The material system,
a lot of it was
developed with the G-mail
team or the Calendar
team of the Search team.
We took time to visit
concepts with them,
iterate on them with
them, and then bring them
back together into sort of a
coherent documented system.
And trying to establish the
relationships between teams
that don't really speak
to each other frequently
is sort of the larger challenge.
But once those are
sort of up and running,
you get that same sort
of camaraderie and drive
towards a common goal.
Like Alex and I worked
together a fair amount
on the branding stuff
as we were-- him
from the Search side and
me from the Material side.
And it's really just
sort of passing back,
like what is the problem
that you're trying to solve?
How can we adjust the solution
to be appropriate for it?
And what else is not even
being considered yet?
ALEX COOK: Yeah.
I think one of the interesting
things about Google-- I mean,
maybe all of the industry,
now-- is that everyone
is designing at scale.
So when you think
about the impact
of like the sheer numbers
of usage that Google has.
But also when we think about
Search and what's that like,
we can't just think
about one search query.
OK, what happens when someone
searches for Barack Obama.
So even something
like the logo change,
we really have to test that
with just tons and tons
of different queries,
put in different contexts
to make sure that
it's going to work
across all the
different situations
that we need it to do.
And that makes the design
much more iterative.
Because you start out
with some good ideas,
you mock a couple of them up.
You start finding
more and more places
that you need to stitch up
the design or fix it up later.
And that leads to the
conversation with Engineering
or and sometimes
changes downstream.
But the conversation
always helps.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
And kind of on that topic
of branding, Katherine,
how would you describe
your team, Brand Studio,
within Google?
What do you guys do and how do
you approach branding products?
KATHERINE WALKER: Yeah.
Well, we do a lot of things.
But I think one thing that we
think about a lot with branding
is how different it's
become nowadays, especially
in the digital era.
Branding used to be, here
is your big tome, bible book
of brand guidelines.
And the brand is telling
the user how to react to it.
And now, it's very different
where people actually adapt.
Or brands actually
adapt to people.
We're kind of in an
interesting tech time
where we know behaviors
and what people want
and what they want to see.
And I think what's important
is that the brand is
very much like a fluid thing
and very much nimble to where--
I'm thinking of a
really good example
I've seen recently is I saw
this Norwegian brand design--
and, again, I'm going to get
a little nerdy here-- where
it was for a shipping company.
And the logo itself would
always evolve depending
on temperature or
wind that was around
in that particular space.
I thought that was just
really, really cool
that the brand could adapt to
surroundings outside of it.
But I think that it's important
that brands do evolve.
And then Netflix is a
great example of that, too.
It used to be DVDs in the mail.
And because of user triggers
that they're saying now
they stream.
They're doing really well.
And HBO's offering a
streaming now, too, for free
so we could be all
be cord cutters.
And I think it's
just really important
that you understand that
users are so much more
influence on brands now.
That's how we have to think.
MIKE DENNY: I already know
the answer to this but--
KATHERINE WALKER: Yeah.
MIKE DENNY: --it would
be fun to discuss.
So how did that kind of--
the evolution of the world
and users, the population of the
world, all of Google's users--
how did the world
changing influence
our recent Google,
company-wide rebrand.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: So I think
a lot of the different mediums
that we expect people to
see things in, like the move
to mobile or needing to
be able handle things
like watches and
TVs, that was largely
what led to the brand redesign.
Also, just sort of the need to
be able to adapt to context.
I think that Search,
as you move to mobile,
becomes something more around
like what is around me?
What is relevant right now?
And being able to indicate
sort of the state of that,
being able to modify your
brand based on temperature,
other things, to show sort
of relevancy and relatedness
to the current situation.
You need a slightly more
flexible approach in order
to handle that and
even handle things
you haven't considered yet that
will come up over the coming
years.
The new system is an
evolution of the brand stuff
that was done a year ago.
And it's building
upon it and adding
more character that's unique
to that specific use case.
ALEX COOK: Yeah.
I think in this day
and age, we have
to think of brand
as an experience.
It's not just a mark.
It's not a set of guidelines.
It's the feeling that users
get when they experience
your brand, your products.
And with the
Assistant, we're trying
to take Google from being
this destination, Google.com,
or this app on your
phone and really
bring it to all the other
places that you need
and find information
in your life
so that it can be that constant
experience that's with you
all the time.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Yeah.
I mean, we've talked a lot
about how we don't necessarily
want to be bound by, you use
the word "tome" of guidelines,
right?
KATHERINE WALKER: Yeah.
MIKE DENNY: And
at the same time,
we've developed material design.
I want to preface by saying that
the goal with material design
was to create a
cross-platform design system,
not just for Google,
but for everybody.
But I think a lot of
developers and designers,
they feel still in that kind
of old mentality of they
feel bound by this large set of
recommendations and guidelines.
So how do designers
and developers
make the best use
of material design
without feeling
restricted by it?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: I
think the main thing
is to approach it as
a foundational set
of recommendations.
If you are starting out,
and you don't really
have a good sense of how
things are going to build out,
it's a pretty good structure
to start looking at stuff.
It's critical, though,
that you don't become so
tied down by those
recommendations
that you lose all character.
This falls in the brand
as well-- making sure
that the applications that
you are designing or building
reflect the character of
your company, the thing
that you're trying
to convey to users,
and ensuring that it doesn't
become so simple or so focused
on just the content in it that
it's not identifiable and not
unique.
Things like the FAB that we
identified for material design,
they're intended
to make people ask
the right kind of
questions, like what is
the purpose of the application?
What do I want to
focus people on?
It doesn't mean that
the incarnation of that
has to be a red circle
with a white icon on it.
It can take any form.
It's really just
sort of a desire
to have focus and move towards
the right kind of patterns.
So for material, looking
at sort of the broader
set of guidelines as
this is a starting point.
What you're really
supposed to do
is take this and build something
that's unique and appropriate
for your product and that makes
your product really stand out.
KEVIN DAME: I
think we're kind of
going through that a little
bit even within YouTube.
Because we have a number of
apps within YouTube, now.
We have our main app.
We have a kid's app.
We have a gaming app.
We have a music app.
And since we started to launch
these apps in the last year,
there have been a lot of
questions about consistency
across the apps.
Do we have too much
inconsistency across the apps?
How much consistency
do we want to have?
And it's a tough one.
On the one hand, it
should feel like it's
coming from-- they should
all feel like they're
coming from YouTube.
But there's a reason why
we made separate apps.
There's a reason why we
had the brilliant insight
that a three-year-old
might be different
than a 27-year-old gamer.
But that's the real
trick is like it
pushes us to think
really hard about how
are these apps different?
And how are they the same?
And it's an ongoing
conversation I
think we're going to have as
these apps evolve over time.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Yeah.
I agree 100%.
So there's kind of an internal
debate in the design community
about whether or not designers
should learn to code.
And I know we have a mixed group
up here with some of us have
engineering background,
some of us don't.
In my experience,
understanding at least
the technical feasibility helps
inform the design quite a bit.
And I know that
designers out there would
love to have that benefit.
Is there an easy way
to get that benefit
without necessarily going and
getting a computer science
degree?
KATHERINE WALKER: I'm staring
at my creative engineer
in the crowd right now.
He's looking at
me, he's like, I'm
ready for you to answer this.
I don't code.
But I sit next to
it every single day.
And I understand
what's possible.
And I think that that's
what's important.
I think the most fun
part of being-- I
was recently a print designer.
And what's coming to Google
and testing these things
in a digital way is sitting next
to a developer, asking them,
is it possible to do this?
And they're like,
absolutely not.
But then they come back
to you an hour later
and they're like, well
yeah, it's possible
if we look at it this way
and it's done in this term.
So all of my work has gotten
exponentially better sitting
next to a creative technologist.
So for me, they're
going to know it better
than I'm going to know it.
I'm always going to be
an expert at the design.
I let them be an expert at dev.
But if you understand it,
you have a great working
relationship, then I
think that that is just as
useful as being great at both.
MIKE DENNY: Post-collaboration,
learning through osmosis.
KATHERINE WALKER: Exactly.
MIKE DENNY: Anyone else?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: The
other thing is not-- well,
having a sense of
what's possible,
both from the engineering
and design side.
And either doing that
by having knowledge
of the other discipline or just
by working closely is great.
The other thing is just, for
both design and engineering,
the ability to convey an idea.
For designers to convey
an idea, sometimes that
shows up as being able to code,
sometimes it's motion design.
A lot of it's
about storytelling.
The same thing's
true of engineering.
Like prototypes often are one
of the most convincing things
that we can use in a discussion
because people can actually
evaluate stuff
versus just guessing
about how it will work.
So people on any side
in any discipline
by thinking about how best
to tell the story of this
or how best to
convey the idea, you
end up being far more effective.
And often that's
done in collaboration
with others and by fusing sort
of those different talents
of design engineering.
ALEX COOK: We use prototyping
for storytelling all the time
on Search and Maps.
Pretty much every one
of our last big releases
has been prototyped
in some form,
and that's what gets
presented to the stakeholders,
the VPs when they make
the design decisions.
When we made a
decision on the logo,
we brought in prototypes
that my team made to the SVP
and was like, this is what
Search is going to look like.
And he played with
it for a few minutes.
And said, OK, this
is the search I want.
Let's do it.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: One point
about prototyping, too,
is that in many cases,
you cannot make a decision
by looking at fake data.
The work we did
on Chrome History,
like any time we did a
design for Chrome History,
if you showed it to
somebody and it was just
sort of a random set of links
that they've never even thought
of, it's not useful.
You can't evaluate it.
If you see your own data
presented in any way
and you can evaluate
those designs,
you make a better decision.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEVIN DAME: Oh, go ahead.
MARTA REY BABARRO: No, no, no.
Go.
KEVIN DAME: No, no, you.
I've been talking.
MARTA REY-BABARRO: No, you made
me think of a very cool story.
I love working very, very
closely with engineering
all the time, daily.
I don't code.
I don't know how I got an A
in Java in my master's degree.
I loved it but I
couldn't believe it
that I ended up
getting that grade.
Like the most undeserved grade
in the history of a Java class,
ever.
Anyway, I remember at one time
we had these great findings
around how HRBS, who
are HR here at Google,
were using this tools that
we use internally, right?
And I had this very great
insight about a tool
that we could do that would
improve their lives by a ton.
So I remember explaining that
after getting these results
from several testing of
surveying several HRBPs and so
on.
So it was great.
And then we were going
to go-- like the business
side was going to take
it, present it all up
the chain in HR.
It was going to be this
like several weeks process
until, yes, we can do it.
And Brendan, who was
one of the developers,
was in this meeting.
So after the meeting
he's like, hey Marta,
what are you doing later?
And I'm like, I'm
going to be working.
He's like, just come to my
desk and tell me what to do.
Let's do it.
And I'm like, serious?
He's like, let's just build it.
And we did.
And it was amazing.
Because I was like
sitting with him.
We were looking at the
UI, making the changes.
And then we just
showed it to everyone.
And they were blown away.
Like it wasn't like these like
series of several meetings
and let's see if it
works or it doesn't.
Like we had it there.
We presented it to the HRBPs.
They loved it.
They adopted it.
I got to do more research,
which is what I love doing.
And it's one of the features
that we have right now
in one of our internal tools.
So stories like that happen.
I encourage you to sit
with your designer,
sit with your researcher
and make things happen.
KEVIN DAME: Can I
take your question
and steer it in a slightly
different direction?
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
KEVIN DAME: OK.
I think this question
of should you--
if I were to change the
question a little-- like if you
are x should you also do y.
And at least on
the Visioning team,
the folks that
I've tried to hire
are people who you might
call hybrid type Googlers who
have a combination of a little
bit of a researcher in them
and a little bit of
a designer in them.
And it's funny
because a lot of times
when they join the company
people will say, hi, I'm Joe.
What are you, a designer?
No.
Oh, are you researcher?
And the answer often is both.
And the reason why I
think it kind of relates
to your question is I
think there's power in--
I don't know if you've heard
of the term "T-shaped" people?
It's kind of a concept that's
been out there for a while.
But the concept of
a T-shaped person
is that they have
an area of depth,
so they're an engineer,
of they're a designer,
they're a researcher.
And then this T is
meant to represent
sort of a breadth of knowledge
or interest in other areas.
So for example maybe
you're a designer by trade,
but you have a little
bit of an appreciation
or a knowledge of
the business side.
Or you have a little bit
of a researcher in you
or you like to code.
I feel like, especially
in the Visioning team,
we look for T-shaped people.
But I feel like in general,
it's really healthy and good
to have some secondary things
that you're interested in.
Because I think it makes you
a little bit more versatile.
I think it allows you
to collaborate better
with other people, gives
you more perspectives
to work with at your job.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Yeah.
One common theme that
has been coming out
in multiple questions
in this discussion
has been the importance
of collaboration
between these disciplines,
sitting down--
designer, engineer, researcher,
designer, researcher,
engineer-- and spending
that time together.
At the same time,
though, everybody has--
or I mean, even
on bigger, larger
cross-organization efforts,
like having lots of meetings
to make sure everyone's
on the same page,
and establishing that
working relationship,
and then actually having the
meetings to facilitate and kind
of maintain that relationship.
How do you strike a good
balance between what's
on your own plate, personally,
and this collaboration, which
we all agree is very important?
A brave person can go first.
MARTA REY BABARRO:
I can take it.
So I'm a researcher by trade.
There are, well, many
schools of thought.
But a couple of
schools of thought
in the research community.
One is, we are researchers.
We have the knowledge of
speaking with the user,
making sense of all these data.
This is a skill that you don't
learn within a day or a month.
We are the ones that need
to be involved in this.
We are the ones
leading the research.
Great.
You know, that's one
school of thought.
And I agree with many things.
And another one which is
the one that I think it's
like, I want to open up
research to everyone.
In every single
sprint, I tell people
I'm going to teach you how to
be a researcher in 15 minutes.
And I'm going to give you tips.
And we're going to have users.
And I'm going to show you
how you can speak with users.
Because what that does is
that it opens up the value
that research is bringing to a
team, the value that research
is bringing to an engineer.
And they have a
better appreciation.
They realize, wow.
Like one of the
things that we teach
them is try not to
ask leading questions,
like very neutral questions when
you're interviewing someone.
Then they realize, wow it's much
more difficult than it seems,
right?
Because we're in love
with this product.
And we want to hear
great things about it.
So then they realize that
it's definitely a skill.
It's very important.
I just finished a
sprint on Wednesday.
And we were thinking
about these type of user
as really needing a lot of data
about how their program would
work.
And then what we
realized through rounds
of research is that
what they really,
really, really care is
to create a new program.
And there is no tool
to do that at Google
for one specific area.
So it completely
shifted the way that we
were looking at the space.
And it shifted what we're
going to be end up coding.
And the calls came, actually,
from one engineer at 1:00 PM
that we're doing this research.
So I'm of the school
of thought of like,
let's have everyone do research.
Speak with your users.
No matter where you're working,
you can get a hold of a user
and just like have
a conversation.
Like you said before,
have a conversation
and listen to your user.
Oftentimes, what you
have in your head,
it's not what the user needs.
Like you convince yourself
that what you want to build
or what we want to build
is what the user needs
or what the user wants.
And sometimes, the
reality is very different.
So having that
conversation allows
us to be more
aligned with the user
needs to build great products.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
So I mean your comment
really goes back
to Kevin was saying about
T-shaped people, right?
So you take your deep
area of expertise.
And you, through
collaboration, share that.
And you help other people
broaden the top of their T.
But we still have
this problem of we
all have our own set of
personal tasks, right?
And what's the
best way to strike
a balance between
collaboration and lots
of meetings versus actually
getting stuff done?
KEVIN DAME: I could
speak to one angle.
But I think it's a-- I mean
it's a very hard problem.
Like I think even just meetings
needs to be rethought across
like all of business world.
Because there's a lot there
to rethink and redesign.
But I will say one
thing, that I think
there's a time and place
for everybody to be
like uber collaborative.
And then there's a
time and place where
we know what we want to do.
And we execute.
And then we trust one another.
And we rely on the depth
that everybody has.
And I feel like, coming
back to Visioning,
I think that's one
of the things that we
try to do by helping a
team create a clearer
vision for themselves,
is once they-- you know,
we talked about trust a lot.
There's definitely
the importance
of trusting one another.
But when they all trust in the
same vision that they created,
then I think it's time
for people to execute
and there isn't a lot of churn.
Because I think a lot
of times what happens
is when people don't feel clear
on what they're doing or don't
agree or don't have confidence,
there's a lot of churn
and a lot of meeting,
second guessing.
When there's a clear
vision and people
feel like we know
what we're building,
we know why we're doing
it, we're confident in it,
then I think people can execute
with like less of a requirement
for this uber collaboration.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
I mean we've also talked
a bit about prototyping.
And it's been said, fairly
famously in the design world,
that a prototype is worth
a thousand meetings.
So I mean, what does
that process look
like across Google?
How does prototyping
help us save time,
but also actually
create better products?
ALEX COOK: So what we
do on Search and Maps
is we have a UX Engineering team
that's about 17 people, now.
And they're partnered
up with Design partners.
And so as soon as designers
start doing design,
we have people in the room who
are actually going and building
these things out.
And we're starting to build
up a culture more and more
that as we go and
present our ideas,
we're bringing them
in prototype form.
So people can play with
them with real data
and see what the actual
experience looks like.
And we want to make sure
that the prototyping is
thought of as part of the
design, not a hand off.
Because when it comes
too late, then you
don't have people who are good
UX engineers bringing ideas
back.
And you don't have
that same situation.
You may only get rushed.
But when you have people who are
right there thinking about it
as the design evolves, then the
prototype can evolve with it
and be that design deliverable.
KEVIN DAME: Is this
phenomenon of guess-a-thons--
I don't know if anyone's
heard the term guess-a-thon,
but I heard it
recently-- but it's
like I remember when we were
working on YouTube Kids.
We would be in meetings,
so a bunch of people
were in a meeting-- and by
the way, like none of them
were parents.
And then they're all speculating
on what a parent would like
and speculating on like what a
four-year-old would do or like.
And then you'll even have
someone like, well, my daughter
can do such and such.
And it's like, yeah, but
you're like a VP at YouTube.
And your daughter's probably
not representative of kids.
And so I think the
value of the prototyping
is like we can waste a lot of
time having these guess-a-thons
or we can just build something
and get a reality check
very quickly.
So I think that's the
value of prototypes
is fewer guess-a-thons,
which are
frustrating to be
in, usually don't
result in the right answer,
and take too much time.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: And even the
act of creating a prototype
is it's kind of
rooted in empathy.
It forces you to think through
how somebody else might
encounter the thing.
One thing that might
be worth encouraging
is just prototyping in
any form is valuable,
even if it's like a
series of static images
that you can flip through really
quickly and get a sense for.
It doesn't have to be like
a complex code-based thing
or a perfectly
polished motion design.
Anything that allows you
to show it to other people
and have them evaluate
it and give you
their feelings about how
it works is effective.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
So kind of to wrap up, we
have a broad representation
of all the different UX roles.
There are lots of different
design disciplines at Google.
And there's lots of overlap
with engineering as we've seen.
What do you look for in a
candidate or in their portfolio
when you're looking at designers
who are applying to Google?
And maybe Katherine to start?
KATHERINE WALKER: Sure.
MIKE DENNY: You look
like you were thinking
really hard about this one.
KATHERINE WALKER: Yeah.
I'm like, so what
answer do I give here?
No.
For me, for the
visual design role,
for what I would hire
for at Brand Studio
I just like a good
way to see concepts,
that they get their ideas down.
If there's a strong concept
behind a lot of work
that they do, that it
was a good idea there.
I think style is something
that you can learn.
I think expression is
something that you can hone.
But like having that initial
idea is really important.
Then also I really am a
stickler for typography.
If someone has good
type in their book,
I am like, yep, hire them.
Get them in today.
And then the last part is
just someone that you can--
you're probably going
to see this person more
than you see your family, quite
frankly, the A that you work
with all day, day in and out.
Are they a good human?
Do you want to sit next to them?
Do you want to go
get a beer with them?
That is another huge plus.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
That's definitely
a general thing
that we look for at Google.
Nicholas, I mean you look
at a lot of different roles.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: Across any of
them like, again, the ability
to tell a story in any form.
For engineers or others,
like engineers or designers,
is just when have
they taken something
they're passionate about and
conveyed it to other people?
And it doesn't really matter
how they go about doing that.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Awesome.
Anyone else have any?
KEVIN DAME: I think
in the Visioning work,
we're kind of looking
for all those attributes.
But there are a few that
we look for that I think
are a little bit different.
Because a lot of times what
we're doing on a Visioning
project is we're taking
something that's either
really vague and undefined
or something that's
kind of all sort of
messed up, we're stuck,
we can't figure it out.
And I think there
are many folks who
would like someone else to
kind of clean that up for them
and say, OK, you've
got a good clean brief.
We know what we're doing.
Now, go be a great designer,
go be a great researcher.
On our team, we've got to
turn clarity out of ambiguity.
We've got to untangle things.
So the number one thing
I look for is people
who are comfortable with
ambiguity, optimistic,
are good leaders, can
make sense of messy stuff.
So you know that's kind of the
number one thing we look for.
ALEX COOK: The storytelling is
really important to me as well.
But I love attention to
detail and fundamentals
in a designer or an engineer.
I love seeing people design
forms when they apply.
It sounds so
rudimentary, like who
wants to look at another form?
But a form is such a
telling piece of design
if someone is a good
interaction designer or not.
You can really see the
thought and the care
that they've put into how a user
will move between the fields
and ultimately hit that Submit
button and complete their task.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
Well, that's all the time we
have for our Design Fireside
Chat.
I want to take the
opportunity to thank everybody
on the panel.
I think we covered a
lot of different topics.
I hope it was useful
to everyone watching.
And yeah.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]